all right Miss Vienna we are here to
catch up with you and it's been a minute
since you've been on camera yes in a
while how does this feel for you right
now um a little uncomfortable but I
think it's like riding a bicycle you're
gonna get back out get right back onto
it this is a very different bike to be
on than the Batchelor bike
we're here at ET you know it's not gonna
be quite so as they say traumatic yes no
roller coaster almost ten years for you
know it since that season is that kind
of crazy to think about yeah people
always ask Mike what year were you and
I'm like a long day Thomas a decade Wow
I was so young do you feel like you were
a different person then I was I was a
little kid I was 22 right out of college
no redo did you have any idea what you
were getting into I had not I had
actually never even watched the show so
I had no clue what I was getting into
when I went on and it's changed your
life for sure yes I'm not even sure
where my life would be if I hadn't gone
on the show it's gotten a lot of
different directions I've lived in la-la
land oh I've businesses so we were just
saying I love how you look as a brunette
so gorgeous but we knew you as a blonde
I know you know the funny thing is I've
always been open at my whole life but in
college for a girlfriend decided let's
go plea to blonde and I just happened to
get cast on The Bachelor wha being
bleached blonde and that I had to stay
bleached blonde for my entire contract
and the day my contract ended I actually
I went and bought a box Brown tie and I
died my own hair in the sink that day my
contract ended I was like finally I'm
brunette again did you feel like you
needed to shed that blonde you know
terrible other brunette all right I look
terrible as a blonde I will never ever
go blonde again well I thought you
looked beautiful but it was there also
something emotional about that I want to
get back to my hair color back to myself
before all this began that and I'm not
I'm not too much of a girly girl so
blonde hair is very high-maintenance I'd
rather you know now I can do my hair
twice a year and I'm kind of good so now
you're brunette do you get recognized
these days or is it less now that your
hair color is different I get recognized
just as much still I they say my smile
gives me away so I get parently I have a
pretty big smiles
well it's good to have a big smile I got
paid a lot of money for this deep so I
always am like mom thank you for that
you're coming to us after quite a last
couple of years for you and you have
undergone some procedures just walk me
through what you had done I know a
couple years ago you guys know I had my
miscarriage I lost my twin girls at five
months and it was really difficult for
me it took me a year just physically and
emotionally just to recover and it was
really difficult because I would look at
myself in the mirror and I wouldn't feel
like myself I you know I had a mommy
pouch and I gained a little bit of
weight and I gained like 25 pounds over
that year just from being depressed and
it was really hard for me and I felt
like I was it was a wound on top of a
wound every time I looked at myself I
hurt and then I get angry and so I was
talking to Erica Ruth and she just had a
mommy makeover and I was thinking you
know it's okay mommies get makeovers all
the time but what about Angel moms you
know I'd like to have a makeover I'd
like to look at myself and feel
beautiful again and look like me so
that's when dr. rose reached out to me
and said well I'd like to give you one
when I get a little teary yet because
the last couple weeks
seeing myself I finally feel comfortable
putting a bathing suit on and finally
feel comfortable looking at myself in
the mirror and not feeling sad I gotta
tell you so much is going through my
mind right now seeing you tear up like
this because what you went through I
can't even imagine and the strength that
it has taken for you to share that with
people and to normalize it it's okay I
think a lot of women we don't talk about
miscarriages it's just in society it's
unspoken since then I've had a lot of
women that have opened up to me and
we've been big support with each other
and there's just a big outlet women that
I talk with now and this was one of
those subjects that we had kind of
talked about between ourselves and you
know wanting to kind of be put back
together you know as I say it and I feel
like making that step will give other
angel mom's kind of the strength to also
feel okay doing it because you feel I
kind of felt that like why am I being so
selfish to care so much about my body
there's more important things but then
at the same time I I want to also feel
be like me and I would imagine you you
touched on this you look at yourself in
the mirror and is what you were dealing
with essentially seeing a reminder of
that loss every day I'd look at my
stomach and I'd have kind of a pouch
where I've been pregnant it was clear
you know you look like you'd had a baby
and it was just a every single time I
looked in the mirror it was a constant
reminder of my loss that must have made
it even harder to try and emotionally
and mentally progress after that loss it
is you know so you go through this year
you're dealing with incredible effects
from your body just because of the
pregnancy and because of losing the
girls right yeah and then is it also
that you're feeling depressed and and
you're I know how it is when we're
depressed we kind of turned to food for
feelings sometimes and that kind of
thing is that what you were going to
have I did I got really depressed the
year-and-a-half after losing the babies
I still found myself not wanting to go
out not wanting to do much I didn't work
out like I used to I just kind of gave
up I notice had to say and I feel like
now it's kind of a wake-up call and it's
get up move go be happy with your life
when your own personal life was there my
mom yeah my mom is here in the studio
now my mom herself had multiple
miscarriages so she knew she knew what I
was feeling she knew what I was going
through so yeah she was look we
shouldn't run from normal reactions to
things and I think what you've been
through crying about what you've been
through processing what you've been
through that's normal in terms of what
you had to undergo um so you were your
mom's rainbow baby I was my mom's
rainbow baby and then um she had four or
five miscarriages after me it took her
14 years to have my youngest sister
Hannah who's also a baby oh my gosh so
one day we filled up my room oh baby
what what goes through your mind with
that do you think about trying to get
pregnant again
yeah the last couple years is kind of
all I thought about that it almost kind
of consumed my life and
that's when I decided now that I'm going
to stop thinking about it I'm just going
to be happy and enjoy my life for a
while and maybe in a couple years
try again so there's a chance that I
might not be able to have my own baby
but I am completely okay adopting okay
yeah so that's kind of rare even
thinking in my head I'm older it's
something that I I need to really think
about so I haven't been trying to get
pregnant though I've just been thinking
I'm 33 now and I know 35 is a high-risk
pregnancy so if I'm gonna try to have a
baby I probably should start thinking
about trying again yeah can I ask
look you were known for being this
personality on The Bachelor maybe
painted in a certain will say villainous
light at some moments do you think that
people have come to you with a new sense
of kindness have have people approached
you differently since you kind of opened
up about all this I think that a lot of
people change their perception after
Jake and ice break up Vienna
people really got to see who I was not
just who I was portrayed so I you know
the last eight years have really not
been that difficult people kind of given
me a chance to get to know me and people
that know me know that it's I'm not a
villain I'm just someone that tells the
truth sometimes a little too much and
the girlfriend that you really want to
have in your corner and I grew up with
around a lot of guys so yeah I wasn't
the girly girl I don't know how to shake
her coat things they don't know how to
be that I don't know miss proper oh well
I mean look you gave us iconic
television I mean Lou sitting on that
bench and Jake talking to you the way
that he did that moment still gets
brought up is one of the best moments in
the show's history just for its watch
ability factor although I'm sure it was
horrible for you yeah I made me strong
it made me really strong he's going
through what I went through at such a
young age I mean like I said I was 22 it
has made me have a very tough skin and a
backbone so so yeah well now so you had
this mommy makeover what exactly for
people who don't know
does that entail okay so I didn't have a
full-on mommy makeover I had like a mini
mommy makeover a for a mini angel mommy
makeover so a mommy makeover is kind of
everything where they do your breasts
they do full body liposuction arms like
stomach tummy tuck I did a mini mommy
makeover which would be my did body
sculpting on my arms I did body
sculpting on my legs and then my stomach
where I had been pregnant they you know
do sculpting in there and lipo and okay
so how many hours are you in all these
procedures all in all you think um I
think it was it's well I was knocked out
but I'm pretty sure it might have been
like three or four hours okay what was
the recovery like painful tough would
you have to do okay so the pharrell tell
you i 100% recommend getting an angel
mall makeover or a mommy makeover to any
woman who wants to do it it the the
first couple days after it it is really
painful you're bruised up everywhere cuz
everything kind of hurts on you from
there you have a 6-week recovery where
you're in a girdle and you have to get
lymphatic drainage massages and help
your body heal but realistically the
recovery wasn't it wasn't really that
bad did you gain quite a lot of weight
with the pregnancy because I know you
had the complications I mean all in all
wear you out on the scale now versus
then okay so before I got pregnant I was
120 pounds I was little after my
pregnancy I was topping about 150
I wasn't gaining weight like I should
have been gaining weight because I was
throwing up a lot when I was pregnant so
they basically said eat anything you
want just eat eat eat so then I started
getting in this you know habit of having
breakfast and a snack and lunch and I
would get up in the middle of night and
have a peanut butter and jelly sandwich
and then when I had my miscarriage I
kind of stayed in that eating habit and
that's kind of where my week is kind of
kept going
my highest that I was was one you know
150 155 right now I think I'm at about
125 130 um so I'm definitely back to you
yeah yeah so how do you feel you put on
a bikini or swimsuit now and how do you
feel ah
so I've put on a bikini for the first
time today yes right here right now okay
put it on today and going in going in
bikini shopping for every woman every
woman hates bikini shopping it doesn't
matter what you look like it is just a
dreadful thing to do you know because I
was a guy everything's kind of covered
on a guy named Rhys it's like not a lot
of coverage going on so I went and I
picked out a few meeting suits and
actually felt really new I felt really
pretty and comfortable in them I yeah it
wasn't as bad of an experience as I
thought it would be and I found a couple
that I really liked and yeah I feel
confident now putting it on how does it
feel for you to stand there to look at
yourself to feel beautiful knowing the
whole journey that it took to get you
here you know it's I can't I don't even
know how to kind of explain it it's it's
one thing to be beautiful and just feel
it but to kind of feel like you've lost
it and kind of gone through this whole
thing to get it back it just I feel very
thankful I do it was it's nice to look
at myself in the mirror and just be
happy for what I see when you say feel
thankful that's such a perspective thing
how has all this changed your
perspective I feel like kind of take
things for granted you know when we're
young we're you know we're hyper buried
behind metabolism and and women who've
never gotten pregnant they don't realize
kind of what happens to your body and a
lot changes you know your hips get wider
you gained all this weight all over you
your body just becomes something you
don't even recognize it anymore so
that's what I mean by being thankful to
you know and how is your relationship
right now I have my boy when we just
celebrated our two year anniversary in
grad we spent two weeks in Europe love
being there soon he's going to see you
in this bikini body Vienna I know had he
ever seen you on the show no do you
still keep in touch with anybody from
the franchise who are you close with the
funny mom I still talk to of course
Erica Rose I sneak with her just a
couple a couple people but no not too
many we've kind of all one our sub
arrays and started over I don't really
do much of The Bachelor I don't know
yeah Hardee's or anything
I kind of ran from the French sounds
terrible but why I was really scared of
them they actually asked you to be on
bachelor in paradise and I was like I
don't know after the what y'all guys put
me there I don't know so they sent me a
clip and they said we'll watch and see
what you think I said okay so I watched
the clip and it was a girl and I don't
remember who it was but she was like
sitting on a step and she was talking
and they made it look like she was
talking to like a raccoon Claire Crawley
yes and I said terrible click to send me
no I'm not doing this show this is drama
this whole is drama I don't want this to
be a different clip in backless no I'm
good good of all the moments to entice
you with I'm not the best whoever
thought that was gonna reel me in
definitely to rethought that clip that's
it well now you're in a relationship so
I guess you're not going back into the
show good okay do you watch them ever no
no I can't I can't it's Jan yeah I never
watched them before so okay
people always ask me who do you think is
gonna win I'm like I don't even know I'm
kind of it I don't know I'm kind of a
nerd so I like yes well the crazy thing
about the crazy thing about the timing
of you sitting here now is next year is
ten years since your season that was
last time we had a pilot now we're gonna
have a new pilot batch oh there's a
pilot badges you didn't know this No
yes pilot Pete Wow he might be a very
different pilot then we're gonna pilot
is he does he fly actual people and
planes Delta that's what chic was he was
a delta pilot I think he flew for a
branch of Delta okay maybe they're going
a delta for casting purpose maybe I do
like flying on Delta though I'll tell
you that I
you've never run into Jake on a plane
happy no I don't know if he's still
flying
I don't either I thought he was doing
like soap operas or something when was
the last time you guys talked ten years
ago when we were on that bench
okay nothing since that and I wouldn't
have done it and if you could I don't
know you please stop interrupting me
the thing is I would have never done
this to somebody that I that I love and
even you would say to him now
you know I don't hold any grudges yeah
the past is in the past
yeah past in the past and I don't hold
me hard feelings toward anymore yeah I
mean look hindsight is 2020 but looking
back anything you would have done
differently yeah I probably would know
what on the show at all yeah I would
have waited so I was a little bit older
I think it was a little too young to go
on the show I was 22 you know that's so
interesting that you say that because
the age does seem to be going down and I
was talking to someone the other day
about how people are getting married
older and older but then the age of the
contestants is younger and younger I
think it was the youngest contestant on
the show Wow I was 22 how old do you
think people should be going on Oh 28
okay cuz I feel like as a woman it kind
of 28 was the age where you've kind of
got your career going on if you and that
direction you've kind of figured out who
you are so you know what you want in a
marriage in a relationship and you're
kind of ready to settle down I thought I
think our early 20s is a little too soon
for most people so I would have waited
I would have waited a little bit and I
got I kind of got the bad end of the
being the youngest because the girls
kind of shamed me for being the young
one on the show I got I gotta hate it
out by the girls because I was the young
college girl so kind of a catch-22 there
yeah I mean so if you if people ever ask
you for advice I'm sure phanpy talk to
you and say I want to be on the show
what do you tell them well just depends
on where they are in their life yes so
so maybe wait if you're young I would
say wait and you probably watched the
show first before you go on and study a
little bit I should have done that too
done a little more the homework okay
yeah well I guess I'll ask you a having
been with the only other pilot bachelor
any pilot II mistakes that the new
bachelor pilot Pete should watch out for
me oh man he is actual pilot I'm not
sure I think anything could be better
than the first pilot I should say that I
mean look as long as they don't do on
the wings of love again ready for a
different song every time we heard that
song I'd cringe a little bit
is it a little triggering it is
I would imagine but I also do will get
up and dance to it because I danced to
an idea to the stars that I know the
dance I will steal just own it
by the way Dancing with the Stars we
just heard Kaitlyn Bristowe talk about
not being on Dancing with the Stars she
said so she said something kind of she
said her piece
she said Mike Fleiss is a piece of you
know what he doesn't like women and he
never let her be on Dancing with the
Stars probably true why do you say that
I mean that's kind of the the idea of
who he was I don't really know him
personally but what I've heard that's
kind of what I'd heard yeah but I don't
know him personally to know cuz you wind
up on the show like you said you'd in
Jake was on it and you danced with him
yeah God dancing what would you do
Dancing with the Stars again I would
like to actually compete on your closest
stars that would be fine we need you to
be at the center of things now Vienna
now is the times yes uh decade later but
come back you love that I really do new
hair at all she's a brunette and she's
here in the ballroom so now that you've
been through the procedures how far out
are you I'm eight weeks out eight Lisa
okay so what do you have to continue
doing it from here - just keep
maintaining or get yep so after you know
you do your six weeks of healing and you
know your girdle wearing and you do your
massages from there it's basically take
care of yourself so you eat right I'm
trying to do more of like a Kido Kido
spell dough which is actually gonna be
easy for me because I'm not a big car
person okay and then working out so I do
yoga um I have a little yoga studio at
my house I forced my boyfriend to get me
you know
floor-to-ceiling mirrors so [ __ ] good
boyfriend I know I know um go running I
have husky dogs okay so take them on
runs and yeah keep up with my cardio and
how will you just kind of continue to
remember the girls from here but also
find a way to move forward that has to
be a bit of a balance that has been what
I've been doing the last couple years so
I think about them every single day
um there's you know I haven't really
taken down a loose stuff in the spare
bedroom that were further nursery I've
been slowly
trying to because I'm never gonna I'll
never be able to let go or forget but
it's just being okay and knowing that
I'll get to see them one day what's the
best piece of advice that you've gotten
on how to process all this or maybe what
you would tell anybody else I think that
you know when it comes to being an angel
mom a lot of the angel moms have reached
out to me and they some are nervous to
express their excitement when they get
pregnant again and they have their
rainbow babies but I say don't be scared
we love hearing that it gives us hope so
every time I hear one of my angel moms
tell me they're pregnant or they just
had their baby like it is the most
amazing thing to hear it doesn't make me
sad it makes me happy and it gives us
hope so that we want to hear we want to
hear it I want to know
[Music]